Film Courage: I’m wondering if can talk
about short films for a moment?
And you talk about how you made your first
short film and when you look back at it now
there are things that you’re really proud
about?
And some can you also touch on some of the
misconceptions filmmakers have about short
films and I know this is your opinion, it’s
not law but you had some opinions about it
and we’d love to hear it?
Chris von Hoffmann, writer/director of DRIFTER,
MONSTER PARTY, WHITE TRASH and more: Yeah,
I understand that a lot of people are very
anti-short films.
I hear these people saying “No one cares
about short films.”
And I mean, there’s an Academy Award for
short films.
Obviously some people care about them but
I get what they’re saying that feature films
(that makes sense).
I was making shorts for years and none of
them were going anywhere and then boom!
I make a feature and then it gets a lot of
exposure and all that stuff.
So I understand that but I wouldn’t have
been able to approach the feature that I did
if it wasn’t for all those shorts that I
was making.
I think short films for me I started to realize
over the years that they’re not at all about
getting representation through those or getting
a big movie out of those.
There was a time that that happened.
I am shocked when people make one five minute
short that goes viral and they get a twenty
million dollar movie.
I just don’t really understand that at all.
I think you really need to earn your stripes
a little bit.
But I think shorts are much more about sculpting
your aesthetic and learning to tell a story
and working with actors, working with truncated
schedules, and just understanding how movies
are made before you jump into a feature.
Making a feature versus making a short, it
really is night and day.
I mean it’s such a completely different
experience.
Like you need to get those warm-up periods
and maybe make shorts that are like 5 minutes,
10 minutes, then maybe a 20 minute short,
getting a little closer to stretching out
a story a little bit more.
Everyone has their theories on things and
I don’t want to knock anything down but
when people say “I don’t care about shorts,
I just graduated film school.
I just want to make a feature right now.”
I hear that a lot from people.
Or people just want to make one short and
then jump into a feature and I remember Rian
Johnson said something (of the newest STAR
WARS movie) and he was saying “Make like
30 short films if you can.”
Make as many mistakes as possible because
that’s probably the biggest thing.
Because making movies is always sort of like
success training.
Experiment, mess up a lot, and always go for
the most ambitious projects.
Always try to approach something that is hard.
And I think a lot of people get so cautious
about them, I think they are so afraid of
failure.
I think they are so terrified of making a
movie that’s a little too dense or a little
too challenging for them to approach in a
short schedule or with no money.
Because if you make something that is super
ambitious and maybe you do totally fail, but
I would rather make something that’s ambitious
and it challenged me so much and it trained
me for the next movies.
And perhaps maybe fail at it than make something
that’s just two people talking to each other
and is just some easy movie just because it’s
more economically realistic.
But I don’t think that’s going to train
you.
I think they can train you on somewhat of
a level but I think if you can do something
really ambitious in a very tight budget like
someone like Robert Rodriguez or John Carpenter
or Edgar Wright even.
I mean those are guys that I look up to.
I understand that Robert Rodriguez and John
Carpenter score their own music and do a lot
of their own stuff but their mentality about
always going for the more ambitious project
and just creating a bunch because John Carpenter
made so many short films like DARK STAR and
then Rodriguez made so many short films before
he made EL MARIACHI and I just think that
short films are very important to do because
I think if you completely neglect them, I
almost sort of think it’s like somewhat
disrespectful I think to moviemaking because
what makes you think you’re so good to jump
into a feature right away?
Scorsese made so many shorts even before Who’s
That Knocking At My Door.
So I’m a very much pro short films and make
as many as possible and just really screw
up as much as possible, make as many mistakes
as possible.
Because one day you might make a movie that
where everything just clicks but you’re
not going to be able to make that movie until
you make those previous movies that you’ve
learned from all those mistakes and just don’t
overthink things, just keep creating.
Keep making stuff.